10 ja was machen wir heute
heute beschäftigen wir ganz kurz mit
diesen mitteln her wir wie sind sie alle
wieder heißt wer ist das schelling
richtig ganz genau das ist der und
wissen sie denn jetzt kommt die
preisfrage lesen sie welcher schelling
disneys welcher schön ist ja die junge
schändlichen sehr gut
ja ich schon gerade mal ob wir haben
also noch nicht so viele aber ich gebe
mir mal das gleiche
und dann kann es auch schon losgehen
als der junge schelling der frühere chef
der fahrer vielleicht zu
das war gerade so um 1800 da hat er
seine schrift geschrieben mit dem titel
ist es ja ist die schrift verfasst hat
1800 wir werden weil sie in ihrer
letzten sitzung darauf eingegangen
wissen sie es
ja
ja hast also sie haben es fast als
system des trans zentralen idealismus
sei so heißt das genau
von 1800 der ware 520 und er war sehr
früh schon damit beschäftigt die systeme
zu bauen und zu bilden und ich weiß
nicht wie es ihnen bei der lektüre
erging war war nicht so einfach ich habe
so ein bisschen zusammenfassung
geschickt finden sie auch auf der app
was gibt s ja sozusagen zur schelling
streep begriff als er de du ziert den
trieb das war so ein begriff von ihm
distanzieren reduziert den begriff oder
vielleicht sogar den betrieb selbst ist
die fragen im rahmen seines systems
transit idealismus wissen sie noch was
die dozieren heißt was ist mit der
option
in der zusammenfassung bin ich nur kurz
darauf zu sprechen dann wissen sie dass
noch die option also anders gefragt was
versteht man gemeinhin unter einer
deflation
wo kommt der begriff der reduktion vor
normalerweise
ja nebenbei den jeweiligen
mathematischen philosophen bei dem logik
kommt dann solle die option vor
und jetzt kann man sich aber fragen ja
wie kann man denn bitte schön den trieb
denunzieren pansen ideen und man sich
das vorstellen muss trieb den platzieren
also kann man sich vorstellen
jetzt kann man aber doch sagen dann wäre
es ja nur eine analyse nicht dass die
tiere aus was im prinzip dann ist da
irgendwie der trieb schon drin aber wenn
das oberste prinzip nicht gilt
dann kann ich auch den politbetrieb
nicht raus reduzieren
aber es schon richtig also könnte man
sich jetzt überlegen wie so eine
logische formalisierung wir haben das
eine prämisse noch eine prämisse
grundsätze aus den reduzieren wir dann
den trieb sowie eine konklusion gewinnen
aus verschiedenen ist das meint er nicht
ganz aber es gibt diese richtung kann
man sich das fürchten
also verdienen ist so viel kann ich
schon sagen aber es würde sonst auch zu
weit führen
für ihn ist der die delegation nichts
was mit einer bloßen analyse zu tun hat
wie sehr bei einer normalen logischen
reduktion der fall ist und analysiert da
etwas raus sondern für ihn ist also
praktisch nichts analytisches nichts ab
rio risch analytisches sondern für ihn
ist der diskussion etwas apriori
synthetisches als der witz bei dieser
reduktion ist das setting glaubt damit
wirklich den trieb also real her zu sein
nicht nur hypothetisch sind wirklich
realität damit zu gewinnen und das ist
natürlich ein sehr sehr ambitioniertes
unterfangen kann man sagen das ist ja
nur hirngespinst gespinste die da
entwickelt werden aber es ist ein sehr
sehr sehr ambitioniertes unterfangen
also der betrieb soll letztendlich
konstruiert werden es noch ein anderer
begriff der konstruktion
sie kennen das vielleicht bekannt wenn
kann von der intellektuellen anschauung
spricht auch die intellektuelle
anschauung spielt keine rolle dann kunst
und sich das objekt in dieser
anschauungs form dieser reinen
anschauungs vor zum beispiel
geometrische figur und das ist verkannt
ja wie sie alle wissen was synthetisches
und vanessa prior ist das als eine
hervorbringung die nicht angewiesen ist
auf erfahrung nichts apostolisches
impliziert und genau so ist es auch bei
schelling zu verstehen dass da dieser
trieb könnte man auch sagen konstruiert
schwere materie dann das wollen ist nach
schilling durch den widerspruch von
endlichkeit und unendlichkeit gestimmt
wie verstehen sie das können sie das
noch mal mit eigenen worden da stellen
wieso ist da im werner schilling ein
widerspruch kuren besteht
im projekt selbst ist aber auch dass
die realisiert sich haben und
entwicklung
also das ist richtig also sagen also um
etwas zu wollen müssen wir immer was
konkretes wolle
das ist ja der witz auch beim trieb der
trieb ist ähnlich wie der appetit wir
hatten den trieb test ich verlinke
nachher nochmal unten in der
beschreibung betrieb test haben sie mal
zu hause doch gemacht werde noch für
sich noch mal gemacht haben sie noch mal
angeschaut also da hatten wir glaube ich
in der ersten frage diesen fall dass ich
auch appetit angegeben hatte und sie
sich überlegen konnten ob appetit was
betrieb zu tun und ich denke schon
und im gegensatz dazu hatte ich dann im
gespräch die option nummer vorgestellt
und dann hatte ich gesagt hunger hat
nichts mit den trieb zu tun
warum nicht das war das argument
ja genau hunger ist so ein recht vages
gefühl ich habe zwar wird es kohldampf
ich habe ziemlich würde jetzt gerne
braunkohl essen sagt man nichts und ich
habe jetzt appetit auf braunkohle oder
grünkohl oder rotkohl und prägen würste
und alles miteinander
das heißt ich habe appetit darauf aber
man sagt dass auch umgangssprache ich
hab hunger auf irgendwas aber eigentlich
ist es nicht ganz korrekt ihm erscheinen
sondern müsste man sagen ich habe
appetit
ich strebe konkret wenn ich sage ich
habe hunger
dann ist es mir eigentlich egal was
jetzt immer noch ich will dass dieses
hungergefühl aufhört da kann ich dann
auch beliebiges ist deswegen ist hunger
nicht so spezifisch wie appetit und
deswegen passt aber tief in meinen augen
besser zum trieb und jetzt zurück auf
diesen punkt also wollen ist ähnlich wie
appetit was konkrete wünsche zum
beispiel können etwas diffus wünsche
vergleiche ich hoffe ich so ein bisschen
mit hunger es nicht genau das richtige
wünsche es ja nicht so spezifisch und
ich so konkret ich habe da so ein wonach
ja das wäre ja schön und das was anderes
das wollen weil es wurden auf einen ganz
konkreten zweck ausgerichtet ist und das
bedeutet wir sie richtig sagen 'bleib
dieses objekt was sind seine gedanken
und vorstellungen unendlich eigentlich
ist und seine freiheit dass ich das fest
als von der unendlichkeit mussten
übergang geben zu ende ist
platonische war ja genau das ist das ich
denke das leben diese richtung
es gibt ja dann auch noch in der
katholischen lehre dieses projekt und
das ewige madcon also spannende frage
ich glaube es ist beide mal einen trieb
noch einmal ist der trieb weniger
kontrolliert und einmal mehr
kontrollieren also führt jetzt so weit
bin ich auch nicht so der experte aber
eine interessante frage und es ist es
wirklich relevant weil sie sich
vielleicht noch an dem anfang der
aristotelischen metaphysik wo ja alles
total sagt alles alle menschen oder mehr
streben von natur aus zum wissen ja
dieses die horex ist diese praxis
das wäre nach richtete erkenntnis trieb
und ich will was ganz konkret viel
erkennen
ich will nicht irgendwas wenn ich etwas
will welche was konkret die sie bestimmt
hat und das ist glaube ich von schellen
richtig gesehen worden dass hier so ein
übergang stattfinden helfen
unendlichkeit zur endlichkeit zu
bestimmtheit und jetzt gehts weiter
dazwischen zwischen diesen polen
vielleicht zu in diesen extremen könnte
man sagen da vermittelt der trieb auf
eine gewisse weise warum vermittelt der
trieb ihr hcd
wir haben schon fünf zuschauer das ist
sehr erfreulich
das muss der akku vom notebook hatten
wir uns beeilen hier also
bis so vermittelt er drin hatten wir
eine schule st
vertriebs schlägt den bogen von der
unendlichkeit aber auch von der
unbestimmtheit hin zur bestimmtheit und
jetzt habe ich gesagt das ist so was wie
willentlich intentional i tät stimmen
sie mir dazu intention ali t
wissen sie was internationalität ist ja
ja genau die gerichte zeit und das ist
natürlich auch etwas spezifisches der
appetit ist auch immer gerichtet der
hunger ist nicht so wichtig und jetzt
habe ich eben dass man mit dem begriff
der intensität versucht zu reformieren
dass nur ein angebot
ich kann es jetzt wieder verblüffen mit
der frage wie man haus arbeiten schreibt
nach oben rechts nach einem video ein
link reihen zur letzten sitzung wo wir
darüber gesprochen haben im hausarbeiten
schreiben
ich halte es immer für sinnvoll wenn sie
sich wieder die klassischen deutschen
philosophie beschäftigen und deren sehr
dunkel und texten die auf ersten blick
gar nicht einleuchten dass sie solche
begriffe intensität zb auch im nächsten
punkt wie mentale verursachen
das ist solche kategorien die aus der
systematischen bereich dass viele so
vielen stammen zum beispiel aus der
analytischen philosophie aber nicht nur
die mit sachproblemen zusammenhängen
dass sie die versuchen auf diese texte
anzuwenden diese kategorie also
versuchen über diese texte auf gewisse
systematische probleme hin zu lesen und
dann können sie aus diesen texten
erstaunlich viel rausholen
dann müssen sie immer auch ein bisschen
rekonstruieren das hatte ich gesagt also
nicht nur passieren ich wieder geben und
dann sagt schelling das intellektuelle
anschauen das macht und dann das ist das
wesen das sie investieren würde ich
nicht vorschlagen sind ihr das was
schelling hier so nennt können wir
besser verstehen wenn wir es im sinne
der intensität oder sowas machen das ist
so mein vorschlag so zu interpretieren
die mentale verursachung scheiben auch
ein wichtiges thema zu sein
wie komme ich denn
geist zum mentalen phänomenen hin zur
konkreten handeln in die wir 2010 auch
so übergangen
das scheint auch der trieb scheint hier
auch eine rolle zu spielen
so haben sie noch fragen zu diesem
zusammenfassenden punkte ja bitte mental
ist richtig aber jetzt könnte man sich
fragen wenn jetzt diese unteren
bewährungs vermögen mental kontrolliert
werden dann liegen sie ja eine neue
einheit und vicht und fichte und
schelling schalen diese einheit von
vernunft und begehren mit dem trieb
begriff auch zu bezeichnen also das ist
der witz weil bei allen unseren denke
das ist das hauptthema
darum geht es bei uns jetzt dass man den
trieb nicht nur als unteres begehung
semmeln auffassen also als etwas wo wir
wie man landläufig sagt getrieben wo wir
nicht her und zwar selbst
wir werden in der letzten sitzung
nächsten sitzungen schopenhauer und der
letzten sitzung vor der diskussion zu
machen wir noch ein ausblick auf sigmund
freud
das hat eine lange tradition diese trieb
des so sigmund freuds antriebe betroffen
hat aber hier in der klassischen
philosophie wird der trieb begriff immer
mehr rationalisiert nur mehr vergisst
immer mehr mit dem willen ein verhältnis
und zwar deswegen erscheint weiter will
der trieb begriff einfach noch viel mehr
als der willens begriff tut so was wie
energie
und konzentration intensität der trieb
das ist da steht viel mehr kraft
dahinter
diese dynamik dynamik erscheint mir noch
mehr im trend begriffe enthalten als
chef des willens das scheint mir der
gutes und er wird also hinten
aufgewertet und deshalb auch schädigen
diese passage ich habe es auch in der
zusammenfassung die ich auch noch nach
unten verlinkt
genau wir stehen aber sehen da öffnet
sich ein ideengeschichtliche kontext
hier kommt ohne bezüge herstellen so
alles dort lässt zu platon zu allen
möglichen viele suchten
so ist es
genau georg wilhelm friedrich hegel ich
habe jetzt seine geburts und sterbedaten
richtig memoriert weil das letzte
sitzung war ich mir nicht ganz sicher
gewesen sich noch ob er nach oben rechts
und links aber zu einem exkurs zu heben
und den hofmeister und allen möglichen
ob er jetzt 18 30 oder 31 gestorben ist
und er es tatsächlich 831 gestorben
wären sie doch welcher stadt
ich gebe ihm drei zur auswahl münchen
wien und wissen sie alle gestorben ist
jetzt gebe ich ihnen drei angebote
phyllis cola wagen gespürt magengeschwür
cholera aber es war auch sehr häufig
will jetzt gar nicht weiter ins detail
gehen also nur soviel zu nietzsche
friedrich nietzsche zu ok also darüber
könnte man auch mal zehn jahren machen
aber philosophen krankheiten aber dass
ok also dieser gute hier hat ein werk
geschrieben und zwar die enzyklopädie
der philosophischen wissenschaften und
der stammt aus verschiedenen jahren die
gibt es in verschiedenen fassungen in
dem jetzt tausende 38 und jetzt muss ich
sagen jetzt wird's wirklich harter tobak
dass wir jetzt hier lesen
er schaut auch schon so skeptisch das
ist jetzt nicht die ultimative heraus
deswegen sei es auch so viele von ihnen
heute da verhältnismäßig viele
jedenfalls waren wir heute mit tegel ja
jemanden bekommen der extrem bedeutsam
ist aber dessen theorie gar nicht so
leicht verständlich ist
jetzt habe ich hier wieder ein paar
fragen nämlich wie denkt des weges von
wollen und trieb oder familie und
trieben passiert mich sehr
dann wieder den titel das verhältnis von
freiheit und trieb ich hatte in der
letzten sitzung gesagt schauen sie immer
so ein bisschen auf das verhältnis von
trieb und freiheit als bringen sie alles
mit dem freiheitsbegriff im verhältnis
des lohns weitere frage wieder in tegel
das verhältnis von logik und trieb logik
jetzt nicht so zu verstehen wie die
logik diese hier eine universität lehrte
hat eine wissenschaften verfasst und das
ist eine logik im detektive oder
analytischen sinne wenn sie logik
betreiben dann haben sie missen
konfusionen sie haben quandt ohren sie
haben variablen sie haben operatoren und
so weiter und so fort aber was sie da
betreiben ist letztendlich immer
analytisch sagen zumindest die
allermeisten analytisch meist
1 machen der begriffs anderen müssen sie
denunzieren von prämissen auf kongressen
und die kompression sind irgendwann im
preis enthalten zu müssen sie daraus
dividieren und das machen wir gerade
nicht mit logik von hegel meint mit lob
so was ähnliches wie schelling meint als
er vom depot zieren reduzieren ist etwas
logisches nach dem klassischen deutschen
philosophie aber nichts analytisches ist
etwas zu in tätig ist also die glauben
dass sie wirklich aus reiner vernunft
aus der logik der begriffe gehalte
herausbekommen gehalt also nicht nur
analytisches wir jetzt so was wie eine
junge sind gerade sind wirklich
systematisch interessante gehaltvolle
begriffe und dementsprechend behandelt
auch hedl ganz ähnlich wie das shell in
diesem system ist rassismus tut den
trieb in einer logischen beziehung
logisch jetzt wie gesagt mit der
konstruktion und vor allem im sinne
eines systems das auch noch ganz
wichtiger trieb in der position im
kontext eines umfassenderen systems der
betrieb hat eine bestimmte position in
diesem system
das bedeutet diese letzte frage das
heißt die entscheidende frage
welchem rahmen welcher disziplin
vorhandene tegel trieb was würden sie
sagen denken sie zurück
ich frage jetzt noch mal rückblickend
zusammenfassend in welcher im rahmen
welcher disziplin gehandelt jugend
betrieb
gibt es mehrere anwohner ja genau
anthropologie finde ich vielleicht am
besten in welchem rahmen welcher
disziplin der handelsschüler getrieben
da gibt es jetzt auch mehrere passende
angucken ich kann einfach zu rufen
ontologie ja kann man sagen im
extremfall jahr weil es auch die
freiheit bezieht und freiheit ist eine
unter logische frage oder meter für sich
fragen ja richtig ist tätig es geht um
die ästhetische erziehung des menschen
was könnte man noch sagen haben sie noch
eine idee
ja
anthropologen soziologie auch inter und
jetzt hatten sie gesagt der titel ist ja
von der ästhetischen erziehung des
menschen also pädagogen könnte man auch
sagen so wie im rahmen macht's regel ja
sie müssen auch
es ist ein
da
ab morgen
verwendung des weisen
in deiner hilfe
ja sie haben es gesagt logik in der not
genau
ja man könnte sagen dass synthetischen
der synthetischen logik als in anderen
logik wo also logisch meint es geht um
begriffe und es geht um das verhältnis
von begriffen und diese logik behauptet
letztendlich gehaltvolle aussagen zu
machen die nicht nur analytisch sind und
auch ding herzuleiten
die dann am ende auch reale
entsprechungen haben also ganz
platonisch die idee der begriff der geht
der wirklichkeit voraus
die idee ist nicht der abstraktion der
möglichkeit wie ich sagen kann
welke dem fdp-politiker bin ich mit
vielen ähnlichen beugen gesehen in
rheydt viele gemeinden eigenschaften
zusammen
es ist ihr platonischen zulassung
die idee der begriff verbirgt oder was
auch immer das der der realität voraus
geht unsere normativen anspruch besitzt
an dem sich dann die realität
orientieren muss also gerade andere
perspektive und deswegen ist uns
heutzutage ihr konto
wir würden sagen begriffe sind
abstraktionen von konstruktion die auf
den erfahrungen passieren ein hebel
sieht das ganz anders
da ist einer platonischen tradition oder
aristotelischen traktion also begriff
ist berichts linguistisches nicht
sprachliches begriff zum mitglied des
fast logisch und theologisches begriff
ist etwas was uns realität wie nun
bezeichnet sind würden wir uns realität
prägt
die richtung dass diese erscheinungen
die präsentieren
nur einen makel zu weniger mangelt auch
eine studie verwiesen und erklärt sich
zur stadt
weil es an sich weder aufrecht weil sie
ständig zb das leben das sich von selbst
produziert muss man tief erkannt haben
gibt es mehr ich eine gewisse
wahrscheinlichkeit dass unternehmen und
natur billigen
vorgesetzte berlin ein solches system
entwickelt wird ein solches ding nach
hause und dann die widersprüche nicht
privaten sich lösung dessen geschwister
[Musik]
das ist eine interpretation zur arge so
könnte man es sehen also jedenfalls ist
ich glaube darauf kann man sich einigen
ist idee mehr als nur oder begriffe mehr
als nur eine sprachliche kombination als
sprache
er hat irgendwie normativen gehalt also
er sagt nicht nur die etwas ist sind
auch wie es sein soll deswegen auch ganz
wichtig zum beispiel sagte im bösen eine
moralische der werden
die ihr inbegriff der handlung nicht
gerecht also ein widerspruch des
begriffs also wir scheitern der
normativität den begriffen technologie
ist nicht nur was unter dem engagement
daran zeigt sich dass es irgendwie dass
die realität sich an ihm messen sich die
begriffe messen sich an der realität
sind die realität unser handeln an den
begriff zum beispiel vom handeln zuerst
könnte man sagen ja als ich sagte ja
schon so auch idealismus und solche
ganzen terminologien sind sehr
problematisch
das heißt jetzt idealismus arbeiten
könnte es sein müssen
der vorrang des intellektuell ist
gegeben des begrifflichen vor dem
empirisch die betonung des
archäologischen vor allem fahren dass
wir mit gedankenarbeit nicht nur bloße
begriff spielerei betreiben sind das
unsere begriffe wie vor bildet kann für
die und das irgendwie auch ihre realität
stärker sind als bloße wie touristisch
vor gericht müssen sich auch die
eine absolute auch dass da
von dieser
gerade
sind die materialabstimmung
das ist drei des eigenen staates nicht
mehr so ich weiß am besten spezielle
ja das ganz wichtig diese real bestimmen
die sach haltigen diese gehalte dass die
mich getrennt von der logik existieren
so dass sie mit der logik dass sie
logisch durchwirkt sind konnte uns sagen
da gibt es einen gegenseite zu kaufen
haben das könnte mir jetzt als geist
philosophiere als idealismus generell
zeichen und jetzt gehen wir über hier
auf die enzyklopädie der fluss ofin
wissenschaften die triebe und die
willkür dann kann auch viel dazu sagen
will ist ja ein begriff der von hegel
und auch von anderen nur für so viele
philosophen sehr negativ behandelt wird
was fällt ihnen zu wild für ein wenn sie
willkür hören ist es haben sie damit
verbinden sie damit positive konnotation
und negativ attraktion negativ warum
wollen sie sagen
ja genau
als beliebig so nach also sie kennen zb
fürstin will ja das ist bloss oder
willkürherrschaft oder häufig sagt man
es ist nur willkürlich na das war doch
nur wie kühle da fehlt doch eine
wirkliche begründung dahinter
ja das ist das ist oder der punkt und
also regel ist lücke etwas eigentlich
sehr negatives für ihn ist das die
falsch verstandene freiheit für ihn ist
willkür die freiheit die sich in so viel
missversteht als er glaubte das subjekt
weiß ich es verstehen indem es glaubt
der bloßen wahl von produktionen in den
bloßen wähle vorgegebenen optionen darin
erschöpfte sich freiheit
da gibt es natürlich jetzt andere modell
von immanuel kant das autonomie modell
wonach wir nicht dass hier freien
trainieren
zwischen vorgegeben optionen sondern wo
wir uns selbst bestimmen nach
vernünftigen moralischen gründen unten
gesetzt und eine forderung vorstellt und
wie uns danach ausrichten
sei es dass wir in folge oder auch nicht
folgen aber dass wir ein bezug zu dieser
normativität immer haben das ist
verkannt sehr wichtig dass verstetigung
der autonomie und hege ist da ganz in
diese richtung verkannt und sagt auch
also dieses bloße wählen das ist kein
richtiger sinn von freiheit und in
diesem kontext kommen jetzt auch die
triebe zur sprache ja so ein bisschen
das praktische sollen ist reelles urteil
die unmittelbaren nur vorgefundene
angemessenheit der seinen bestimmtheit
zum bedürfnis ist für die
selbstbestimmung des willens animation
und ihr unangemessen dass der wille das
ist die an sich seien der einheit der
allgemeinheit oder bestimmtheit sich
friede das ist für sich sein soll die
angemessenheit sein
bestimme und des daseins durch ihn
gesetzt sein
der wille ist der form des inhalts nach
zunächst noch natürlicher würde
unmittelbar identisch mit seiner
bestimmtheit trieb und neigung insofern
die totalität des praktischen geistes
sich in eine einzelne der mit dem
gegensatz überhaupt gesetzten vielen
beschränkten bestimmungen legt ist er
leidet louis sind sie daraus schlau
geworden
die frage stelle ich auch an meine
zuschauer auf meine drei zuschauer auf
filou kaarst
das sind die weniger geworden der text
wird schwieriger
ja
erste satz
was
er ist
das
subjekt sich was es hier alles okay dass
die hasen komplett verstehen dass
praktisch soll im urteil ist jetzt
wissen wer in diesem wählen das angeht
aber der wille dass das vermeintliche
essen oder den tee kann sich eigentlich
und zufrieden geben dass er zufällig
etwas erhöhen
wie kommt es um versicherungen genau
heißt diese abhört
aus sich heraus gut das sagt auch der
zweite satz die unmittelbare nur
vorgefundenen angemessenheit ja also das
verstehe ich unter dem was sie für den
apfel bezahlt also wird das unsere geben
von aus zu optionen die wir jetzt wollen
könnte das wäre er noch so ein bisschen
vielleicht nach hinten sagte der wille
ist der form des inhalts nach zunächst
noch natürlicher
also der scheint angelegte sein so eine
gewisse herausbildung des willens nach
von den bloßen natürlichen willen der
leidenschaft ist hin zu allem was könnte
man ja dass ich überlegen wohin bildet
sich der trieb
ja gut
das glaubt so kann man sich das
vorstellen und zwar mit harry fremd wird
können sie wieder diese first second
ordervolumens anführen
also first order sind die dinge die uns
unmittelbar und kassieren offizieren
second order das wäre dass dieser
vernünftige wille der darüber
reflektieren kann man so könnte man zum
beispiel jetzt daraus ein bisschen mit
der neue terminologie so was anzufangen
im praktischen gefühl ist es zufällig ob
die unmittelbare aktion mit der inneren
bestimmtheit des willens übereinstimmt
oder nicht
diese zufälligkeit dies abhängig sein
von einer äußeren objektivität
widerspricht dem sich als das andere für
sich bestimmen zu erkennen
die objektivität in seiner subjektivität
enthaltenden wissen will
dieser kann deshalb nicht dabei stehen
bleiben seine eminente bestimmtheit mit
einem äußerliches vergleichen und
übereinstimmung dieser beiden zeit nur
zu finden sondern muss dazu
fortschreiten die objektivität als ein
moment seiner selbstbestimmung zu setzen
linie übereinstimmen seine befriedigung
also selber hervorzubringen
dadurch entwickelt sich die wollen die
intelligenz umtriebe
dieser ist eine subjektive will's
bestimmen die sich selber in ihre
objektivität gibt dieser damit ist
wahrscheinlich der triebe gemeint obwohl
der vortrieb
nicht alle seien diese aber erwähnt
als er unterscheidet jetzt den trieb von
verschiedenen anderen formen des vom
intensität könnte man sagen von
gerichtet hat oder auch von scharfen
motiven nationalen einstellungen zb hier
praktisches gefühl dessen motive
einstimmung wobei praktisch der condor
wieder das volition ali das willentliche
betreiben und im vorwege tat hatte er
unten noch geschrieben leidenschaft
leidenschaft griechisch partie von außen
passen also was ich von außen er leide
dass es eben gerade nicht dieses
subjektive subjektive will uns bestimmen
ihre objektivität
das ist also jetzt der witz des triebes
das ist der trieb ist wollende
intelligenz das ist wieder die fusion
von etwas ihr triebhafte oder etwas ja
nicht unbedingt gleich rationale mit der
rational kontrolliert instanz das passt
auch wieder zu platon wo wir davon
sprachen dass der obere seelen teil des
logistikern diese unsere seelen teile
ist objektiv also diese ganzen anderen
dinge beherrschen müsse und jesus aber
nichts ist er als beherrschung zu
verstehen so inszeniertes fusionierenden
der einheit es wahrscheinlich immer noch
ein bisschen was aus holen also
zufälligkeit ist auch den hügel in der
vierten zeile fünfte zeile hier
zufälligkeit spricht es ist immer bei
hegel nichts gutes also verhält ist die
notwendigkeit immer ein guter begriff
die notwendigkeit
wobei wir heute eigentlich auch den
würden notwendigkeit ist nicht so gut
dass sie mir gerade nicht frei darin an
der notwendigkeit verwickelt ist die
notwendigkeit die freiheit das ist
wieder ein bisschen paradox das was
notwendig ist ist begründet und deswegen
gerade nicht zufällig oder willkürlich
und darin ist es ihm gerade zumindest zu
einem bestimmten trieb das da bleibt der
ball war sie jetzt da wahrscheinlich
auch noch dann fragen würden ist aber
wie sieht's denn jetzt mit uns ohne
niederen triebe aus
geld genau und das dürfte also ist eben
die frage wie er den trieb genau
versteht
ich glaube er würde sagen das ist mir so
etwas wie leidenschaft hier unten
leidenschaft ganz unten wobei hier sagt
der wille hier dies hier wo ich gerade
wenn mauszeiger darauf hat der wille ist
der form des inhalts nach zunächst noch
natürlicher will unmittelbar identisch
mit seiner bestimmtheit trieb und neigen
also jetzt ist dieses nicht ganz klar
ist jetzt der wille identisch mit dem
trieb wie verstehen sie das
hier
wir sind bauen die verschiedenen
im ersten
die niederen bestehen
das
soest
im 2
ok
die kosten ist kein kloster viele sind
los
das ist aus sich selbst heraus im ersten
fall dass das global auch einen großen
eingehen und die zeiten voraus
gut also man könnte zum beispiel also
mit der form das leuchten einer könnte
auch sagen wir könnten dem trieb nicht
direkt ansehen ob er jetzt natürlicher
trieb es oder was auch immer sein
hintergrund ist der witz hier bei diesem
zitat ist dass die vernunft am ende
triebhaft wird dass sie zum trieb sich
veredeln kann
sie steigt nicht herab wie es manche
triebe sind sondern man muss es von der
vernunft tätigen und vernunft wird zum
trieb das heißt sie wird so kräftig so
dynamisch angereichert das ist ja
medientreff ist es aber an andere trieb
als ebenso ein trick der hat eine andere
geschichte
so muss man die triebe haben eine
geschichte hinter der eine hintergrund
des triebes vernunft ihr von den vorigen
ist der hintergrund des triebes eben die
fehlende reflexion die leidenschaft und
mit bestimmtheit gewinnen können also
ich glaube wir haben es hier wirklich
mir diese ambivalenz wieder zu tun die
wir auch schon am rande einer ganzen
texten zahlen das trieb begriffs und die
den die klassische deutsche philosophie
oder unsere diskussion hier auszeichnet
der trieb wird ambivalent in der
klassischen deutschen philosophie und
zwar insofern hat ambivalent interessant
als er eben auch gerade rationale
bestimmungen beinhalten wie in diesen
tagen
sehen sie das ähnlich oder
hier auch solche wendung mit dieser kann
deshalb nicht dabei stehen bleiben
stehen bleiben das heißt hegel denkt das
ganze immer als prozess muss immer
weiter gehen
die lok die bewegung in dynamik das ist
seine logik wird sie kennen auch die
dialekte kann zwischen richtig electric
dass es für hediger mond zu bewegungs
prinzip alles muss immer weiter gehen
es muss fortschreiten hier sagte dass
also von selbst hervorzubringen
seine befriedigen muss selbst
hervorzubringen die objektivität als ein
moment seiner selbstbestimmung zu setzen
also nicht objektivität so zu verstehen
dass wieder was liegen haben ein
gegenstand und nach dem streben ja und
wir müssen den gegenstand selbst hervor
und dadurch sind wir eben autonomen und
nicht mehr nur willkürlich das heißt wir
produzieren hier gegenstand wir bringen
ihnen hervor wir schaffen ihn und nicht
nur wir haben mehrere gegenstände liegen
und werden uns dann ein aus dass der
unterschied das erste könnte man als
willkür bezeichneten zweite nach kant
autonomie oder eben nach hegel freiheit
müssen sie die notwendigkeit betrieben
muss von der bloßen begierde
unterschieden werden die letztere gehört
wie wir in § 4 126 gesehen haben dem
selbstbewusstsein an und steht somit auf
dem standpunkt des noch nicht überwunden
gegensatzes zwischen dem subjektiven und
objektiven die begierde
es ist etwas 1 und sucht nur das einzel
zu einer einzelnen augenblicklichen
befriedigung der trieb hingegen da er
eine form der wollenden intelligenz ist
diese reform
geht von dem aufgehobenen gegensätze des
subjektiven und objektiven außen umfasst
eine reihe von befriedigung somit etwas
ganzes allgemeiner sogleich ist jedoch
der tri als fand der einzelheit des
praktisch und erfüllen sie herkommen und
nur die erste negation derselben bildend
noch etwas besonderes deshalb erscheint
der menschen sofern betrieben versunken
ist als unfall finde ich ein sehr
gehaltvoll das zitat damals einige
weitere bestimmungen für uns
weiterhelfen
den trieb zu verstehen und zwar immer
lohnen sie das in kontrasten zu denken
also freiheit versus willkür oder trieb
in diesem fall versus begierde begierde
was ist jetzt unterschied also wie
inwiefern steht jetzt die begierde noch
im widerspruch von subjektiven und
objektiven wir sind sie auch so ein
bisschen an schelling ging sie zurück an
stellen
der letzte sitzung hatten mal nach oben
rechts mache ich wieder ein link zu
dieser stellung sharing gestiftet haben
wahrscheinlich ging auch aus für diesen
gegensatz sagst das objektiv ist ein
bisschen das endlich subjektiv ist
unendlich in diesem dieser inzwischen
bereich wo vermittelt werden muss also
das subjektive es objektive das ist noch
nicht vermittelt was ist daran schlimm
dass es eine nicht vermittelte ist warum
ist das denn schlimm könnte auch sagen
hier ist ein subjekt objekt
verständnis voraus das ist also recht 1
nr
und s
es ist längst an die regierung und auch
wir nur so beschreiben dass sie
konsumieren damit brauchen stehen was ja
in guter vergleich mit es erhält recht
elektrisiert darin besteht dass das eben
daher gar nicht so sehr herr ist für den
knecht braucht um herr zu sein
also das ist immer der witz pegel diese
ganzen widersprüche sind eigentlich nur
vermeintliche widersprüche die noch
nicht durchschaut sind weil es immer nur
in sein können nicht als etwas fixiertes
als objektivität kann man eigentlich
fixiert damit gibt man umgehend punkte
das ist der witz und die müssen dank
immer wieder in der ihre direkten
verbundenheit bezogenheit müssen sie
aufgeklärt
für den neuanfang zu kommen konnten ja
sein
okay sie ja als ich finde es interessant
in bezug darauf bin ich jetzt selbst
noch gar nicht darauf gekommen
kann man gerne nachgehen also dieser
gegensatz zum beispiel könnte man sich
auch überlegen woher kommt denn jetzt
die objektivität überhaupt da kann man
schon wieder bei kant anfangen kann
würde auch sagen so lägen nur rational
oder sagt objektivität ist nichts was
die subjektivität kategorisch gegenüber
steht das mit den kanaren zu zeugnissen
zu singen
das hätte sicherlich sehr gefallen hat
jedoch auch gefahren
das ganze sei ein system gelöst hat
subjektivität und objektivität
objektivität ist mit leistung der
subjektivität
danach kann bekomme ja diese
objektivität der erkenntnisse nur durch
unsere kategorien des verstandes
gegenständlichkeit substanz aktie dienst
weiter sind aber leistung und zweitens
cent anzubieten die katze das heißt auch
hierbei kann ist objektivität
subjektivität nichts was nicht ermittelt
werden miteinander existieren so nicht
unabhängig voneinander an das ist wäre
jetzt ein größeres system ein system
theoretischer hintergrund wäre ja
richtig und und und bei kant auf das
ding an sich und so weiter sofort also
da gibt es noch dieses de hat sich
betrachtet also dass regel riesenproblem
weil damit eben doch nicht objektivität
richtig vermittelt ist ja gegen das ding
ist an sich das ist richtig der gipser
gibt es ein problem
aber ich sage es ist auf jeden fall
interessanter punkt
und jetzt haben wir ein weiterer punkt
nämlich sie die begierde ist das einzige
sucht nur das einzel zu an einzelnen
augenblicklichen befriedigung betrieb
hingegen da er eine form der wollen
intelligenz ist form das heißt hat was
allgemein ist daher wollen intelligentes
geht von dem aufgehobenen gegensätze des
subjektiven und objektiven aus umfasst
eine reife und frieden somit etwas
ganzes allgemeines als wenn wir jetzt es
subjektivität objektivität als
gegensätze ziehen dann haben wir das
problem dass wir immer nur partiell im
sinne jetzt dirigierte das begehrte
objekt erfasst
wir wechseln als auf die objekte zeit
darüber von der webseite und befriedigen
jetzt irgendwie ein bedürfnis dirigiert
und dann tritt die begierde aber wieder
auf also ich muss mal wieder zum objekt
hin springen von so klingt diese brücke
muss kanzler gefunden werden aber eben
nicht dauerhaft also immer noch instanz
und das scheint ihr damit wenn ich ihn
recht verstoßen haben und im trieb ist
eben so dass hier dieses dieser stütze
diese kluft zwischen der subjektivität
und der begehrten objektivität dass die
überbrückt wird eben im trend dass der
trieb geben das ganze umfasst also ist
er trieb angekommen ist und vertrieb hat
die objektivität einbezug in seiner
suppe tätig und nicht nur einzelnen
instanzen
insgesamt betrieb ist also etwas was
fink allgemeiner greift als ist nur die
begierde
die neigung und leidenschaften haben
diesen bestimmungen zudem inhalte als
die praktische gefühle und gleichfalls
die vernünftig natur das garn ist es
einerseits grundlage andererseits aber
sind sie als dem noch subjektiven
einzelnen villen an gehörig die
zufälligkeit behaftet wie der
zufälligkeit ganz schlechter begriff
beheben
fast wie willkürlichkeit und scheinen
als besondere zum individuum wie
zueinander sich äußerlich und hiermit
nach umfragen notwendigkeit sich zu
verhalten hat jetzt spricht er hier aber
auch von der unfreien notwendigkeit das
ist doch interessant wie verstehen sie
das jetzt
hmm
ja
das wird es keine geben
und bei 1
naja
verschiedene messen durften ja aber
nicht in dieser deutlichkeit die waren
der die allgemeinkosten elemente stand
also die frage
es los
als nicht autonom nicht autonom würden
sie sagen ja ich bin so in jede
beliebige gilt als umfragen versprechen
vom heim zu den frauen leben zu nehmen
und dann gibt es nur einen bereich in
dem man freiheit ist in dem alter stelle
die unterlippe nicht wirklich was sind
die wurzeln und von diesen andere
einflussgrößen auf eine andere ist nicht
regelt sein sollten zum beispiel in der
möglichkeit aber die haben
vernünftigkeit diese anwendung zu
bringen
[Musik]
ja also ich glaube dass es richtig es
geht eben nur darum wie diese tour
veredelt wieder reflektiert betrieb muss
genug reflektiert und hier aber darauf
hinweisen wenn jetzt darauf nicht mehr
eingegangen sind wir nämlich
einschränkung jetzt hier sagt der trieb
ist obwohl er über der begierde steht
ist er immer noch problematisch und zwar
weil er von der einzelheit des
praktischen gefühls herkommt aber die
negation der dieser bildet als er hat
nicht die die die synthese von von von
praktischen gefühl und trieb diese nicht
überwunden ist nur die negation des
gefühls und insofern gibt es vermehrt
der trieb logisch gesehen genetisch
gesehen von der begehrte immer noch
einen moment des besonderen und das ist
für edel schlicht die vereinzelung das
ist welche sind können sie ganz frisch
und seine jugend schriften könnte das
lesen die vereinzelung die subjektivität
schlechte individualität das ist alles
nichts gut versiegelt sondern muss immer
das allgemeine genauer das notwendig
sein also der trip ist in diesem staat
immer noch problematisch aber nicht so
problematisch wie begehrt weil er
reflektierter ist aber ist richtig er
hat immer noch was thematisch soll sich
plötzlich traten andererseits aber sind
sie die neigung leidenschaften als dem
noch subjektiven einzelnen villen
angehörige mit zufälligkeit behaftet und
schein als besondere zum individuum wie
zueinander sich äußerlich und hiermit
nach unfähigkeit zu halten also
vereinzeln auch äußerlichkeit deswegen
über was schlecht äußerlichkeit das ist
noch das fremde ist objektiv das noch
nicht mit der subjektivität vermittelt
das ist ja hier die vorschau für
wirklich organisiert allgemeinzustandes
der niedrig die betrieb wäre eine freude
die repression der straße zu gehen und
das ist eine haupt- und die
allgemeinheit der triebe es waren die
rollen
waren es zu können weil es so viele
emotionen trieben und gut ja also dass
israel diese betriebe müssen einerseits
integriert werden um dieses ganze aber
sie müssen nicht nur wie in so ein gefäß
hereingelegt werden sind in der relation
zu länder
was sind koordiniert werden abgestimmt
werden und vielleicht sogar wir hätten
immer so schön sagt aufgehoben wäre
davon höhere ebene gebracht werden das
ist glaube ich ein wichtiger punkt
deswegen gibt es aber hegel dann auch
noch den objektiven geist dass die
sphäre des jähnigen wohlleben regeln des
zusammenlebens ist wie zum beispiel
mobilität unterster stufe werden ist das
objektive geist
die sinnlichkeit 70 darin kommt es eben
nicht mehr darauf an dass uns die gebote
der moral entgegenstehen
persönlichkeiten sittlichkeit haben wir
diese gebote so widerlegt dass wir sie
in institutionen und kosten kann zum
beispiel in staatsverfassung oder
familienstruktur bürger durch
gesellschaftliche vorbilder tätigkeit
müssen nicht immer überlegen was jetzt
richtig und falsch war kann zu massiven
test sondern leben wir in einer
situation die an sich schon moralisch
genommen dass wie in starken staat zu
fassen hatten sie sich gemeldet
oder aber das kam nicht okay und halte
wir sehen hier greifen wir schon über zu
vielen interessanten punkten bei igeln
die leidenschaft enthält in ihrer
bestimmung dass sie auf eine
besonderheit der welt bestimmen
beschränkt ist in welcher sich die ganze
subjektivität des individuums versenkt
der gehalt jeder bestimmen mag sonst
sein welcher will
und dieses vermeldet willen aber ist die
leidenschaft wirkung noch böse diese
form drückt nur dies aus dass ein
subjekt das ganze lebendige interesse
seines geistes talent des charakters
genusses in einem inhalt gelegt habe es
ist nichts großes
ohne leidenschaft verbracht worden noch
kann es ohne solche verbracht werden es
ist nur eine tote zu oft heuchlerische
moralität welche gegen die form der
leidenschaft als solche losziehen
also hier wieder leidenschaft
beschränkung das besondere das ist nicht
gut nach regeln ja auch individualität
subjektivität als solcher schlecht
obwohl er jetzt sagt walter von mails
zwischen doch lösen
ja
würde ich nicht sagen
ich glaube dass es nicht eine frage des
grades sowie wird ihr sagen der
fehlenden reflexivität leidenschaft hat
eine hohe intensität bestimmt aber damit
ist im verbund die fehlende reflexivität
die fehlende reflexion die fehlende
verlässlichkeit bei der neuen chef
als ich glaube nicht dass die
intensitäten direkt des problems sind
die fehlende flexibilität
jetzt sagt aber komischerweise er
seltsamerweise es ist nichts großes ohne
leidenschaft vollbracht worden
noch kann es ohne solche leidenschaft
verbracht werden es ist nur eine tote er
zu oft heuchlerische moralität wer sich
gegen die form der leidenschaft als
endlich los zu sagen
das würde ich jetzt so nicht daraus
schließen könnte kannte das fragen aber
ich würde so der beantwortung also die
leidenschaft hat den vorteilen der
intensität das würde ich als vorteil
sehen aber den nachteil ist die fehlende
flexibilität dhb etwas großes schaffen
wollen brauchen wir leidenschaft das
moment der leidenschaft intensität plus
eben noch die reflexion dh die
leidenschaft ist eine notwendige
bedingung für das gros ist aber keine
hinweise was anders wieder zu wenn sie
nicht da ist scheint es nicht möglich zu
sein zu lesen ich das jetzt nichts groß
und landschaft das heißt wenn nicht
leidenschaft da nichts großes nicht
direkt also nur als isoliert es lässt
sich vielleicht eine leidenschaft winken
die man vielleicht gar nicht mehr
leidenschaft werden darf was uns frage
aber es lässt sich eine form verkommt
ensi tätigen die eben noch zusätzliche
flexibilität hat
ich glaube nicht dass edel sagen möchte
hört auf eure leidenschaft und macht was
ihr wollt und ihr werdet das großen
regen
das würde ich jetzt nicht aus diesen
text rauslesen zu aber er würde
sicherlich sagen wir brauchen um so
etwas energisches man muss es in
bergisch abgestimmt sein
auf den kontext es muss vergeistigt aber
eben geistige energie er spricht zum
beispiel auch für den
handtaschen taumeln der logik das ganz
lustig bei hitler finden immer mit
tauchern oder auch einig begriffe aus
einem gegenstand bereich der eine gar
nichts und reflexion zu tun hat dass das
spannende bei regeln und die prägen so
dass sie plötzlich für ihn die
wichtigsten metaphysischen begriffen
werden weil sie eben junge stiftung ist
bekanntlich taube an dem keim blieb
nicht trocken sein es ist für ihn die
dialekte gelogen
wir wissen schon praktisch dass die
bachen leider unserer teilnehmer gerade
weg der sich der aus kämpfen dass akkus
ist ja gott des weines ist der
lateinische das lateinische wort zu
dionysos welches dann wird es alle da
geht es beschwingt zu dennoch es regelt
diese beschwingtheit wenn sie vergisst
als vettel lässt sich geister
beschwingtheit als er sich unters
weingeister so er aber auch der demo hat
er immer was doppeldeutigen griechischen
hatte den denken heute muss ein guter
ist diese doppeldeutigkeit und die
versucht titel jetzt wieder zu gewinnen
aber bei den neigen wird unmittelbar die
frage gemacht welche gut und böse im
gleichen bis zu welchem grad guten brot
bleibt und da sie besondere gegnern
ihrer viele sind wie sie sich dass es
sich doch in einem sowjet befinden und
sich nach der erfahrung nicht wohl alle
befriedigen lassen gegeneinander
wenigstens einschränken müssen es hat
mit diesen vielen trieb und
zunächst die selbe bank nist wir mit den
seelen kräften deren sammlung der
theoretische geist sein soll eine
sammlung welche nun mit der menge von
trieben vermehrt
also hier ist auffällig dass er jetzt
von den vielen trieben unten halten
spricht ist nach reden auch immer so ein
schlechtes zeichen
weil die vielheit braucht über die
einheit also was du diesen verschiedenen
vielen trieben und neigungen
kann es auch geben
ja also zb sagt jetzt ahnt dass die
neigung an sich weder gut noch böse ist
und sie neigen müsst nach kant
eigentlich indifferent es kommt darauf
an was wir mit ihr machen erscheint
jetzt neigung als solche schon zu
qualifizieren
sie lassen sich nicht alle befriedigen
und das ist für innere befriedigung
zustand also diese koexistenz
verschiedener betriebe in unser wir
wollen nicht viele triebe haben denken
sie zurück ein schüler
schiller hatte schon probleme damit 2
trieben zu wir mussten müsste er gleich
vermittelt durch leben durch den
ästhetischen leben mit dem spielgerät
durch die partnerschaft war werdet sie
also sehen das ist immer ein problem es
mit der vielheit zu tun haben
die formelle vernünftigkeit des triebes
und der neigung besteht nur ihrem
allgemeinen triebe nicht als subjektives
sein sondern durch die tätigkeit des
objekt selbst subjektivität aufzuheben
realisiert zu werden
ihre wahrhaft vernünftigkeit kann sich
nicht in einer betrachtung der äußere
reflexion ergeben welche selbstständige
natur bestimmungen und unmittelbare
triebe voraussetzt und damit des einen
prinzips und zwecks für dieselbe
gemangelt ist aber die immanente
reflexion des geistes selbst über ihre
besonderheit wie über ihre natürliche
unmittelbarkeit hinauszugehen und ihrem
inhalte vernünftig keine objektivität zu
geben
worin sie sich als notwendige
verhältnisse rechte und pflichten sind
das ist jetzt auch noch mal ein
spannendes zitat halt noch mal gut dass
sie darauf hingewiesen haben der trieb
ist nur er hat eine gewisse form der hat
eine formale vernünftigkeit und die
neigung auch
also
die subjektivität aufzuheben
die dritte zeile durch die tätigkeit des
objekt selbst subjektivität aufzuheben
wie verstehen sie das
er sagt sie gleich danach realisiert zu
werden
einzelne
zu realisieren
geht so
ja ich sehe es jetzt gar nichts dass er
als begrenzt sind einfach nur ganz
glücklich schauen sie wenn sie von einem
zweck zum objekt kommen wenn sie anhand
um realisieren
dann wird das ganze objekt also
manifestiert sich das alles was ist
damit gemeint also vom das ist dieser
mit dieser widerspruch von dem auch
schilling sprach unendliches und endlich
ist als wir realisieren immer was in dem
wir etwas tun in der welt das schaffen
wir fakten also unsere intentionen die
geringen unsere pläne die werden kann
jeder sehen sagt äußerung den übergang
vom subjektiven zum objekt seine
subjektive und aufgehoben
ihre wahrhaftigkeit kann sich nicht in
einer betrachtung der äußeren reflexion
ergeben welche selbstständige nation
bestimmen und mittelbetriebe
voraussetzen damit dass ein prinzips und
sechs für diesen mangel als er will für
diese triebe ein einheit expansiven nz
haben ist aber die immanente reflexion
des geistes zu apps über ihre
besonderheit über ihre natürliche umwelt
weit hinaus zu gehen und ihren inhalte
vernünftigkeit objektivierte geben da
sitzt er willst ist dieses sektors
der geist kann auf die triebe die
nährwerte geist wissen bewusstsein in
uns in sich selbst erkennt oder spüren
objektiv er kann sie formen er kann
ihnen hier ein prinzip und einem zweck
geben betriebe als solche haben nicht
diese einheit die aus richtung obwohl
sie schon der ausrichtung haben einen
erst ordentlichen eine aus richtung
erster ordnung können wir ihnen eine
ausrichtung 2000 durch die geister
und dann wird das ganze werden die
ganzen dinge nicht mehr nur subjektiv
sein werden sie notwendige rechte und
pflichten als zum beispiel bei dem rad
handelt ja so langsam
schon mal wieder akku noch hält 13
minuten machen noch fünf minuten dann
doch ein bisschen die optik diese
objektivität ist es dem weg ihren gehalt
sowie ihr verhältnis zueinander
überhaupt ihre wahrheit aufzeigen wie
platon was die gerechtigkeit an und für
sich sei mit wahrhaften sinne auch
insofern er unter dem recht des geistes
ist eine ganze natur befasst
nur in der objektiven gestaltete
gerechtigkeit mit der konstruktion des
staates als es täglichen lebens
darzustellen darstellen zu können zeigt
welche also die guten vernünftigen
neigung und deren unterordnung sein
verwandelt sich in die darstellung
welche verhältnisse der geist
hervorbringt in dem er als objektiver
geistig entwickelt seine entwicklung in
welcher der inhalt der selbstbestimmung
die zufälligkeit oder willkür verliert
abhandlung der drehbewegung und
leidenschaften an ihrem wahrhaften
gehalt ist daher wesentlich die lehre
von den rechtlichen moralischen und
sittlichen pflichten das jetzt noch zum
schluss wir machen denn da gar nicht auf
offline weiter was jetzt der witz dieses
zitat ist knüpft jetzt an gibt das
vorherige zitat an
das ist hier in der der geist sich als
objektiver geist entwickelt das ist dass
dieser übergang dem letzten zitat er
wird wo die neigungen und triebe bilden
sich zu objektiven verhältnissen
notwendigen verhältnis werden objektive
geist der
verhältnissen groß dass keine
partikularen zu einer
ein wenig besonders der reichtum an
unterjocht dann die anderen clip aber
unser ist
die aktivierung dieses recht auch ein
richtig der anderen ist es genau zu
wahren und es ist nicht einfach möglich
dass seine genau das ist zb eine
struktur des objektiven geistes und das
scheint das ziel sein dass der geist als
geist ist dass da eine reflexion auf die
betriebe stattfindet die diese triebe im
größeren zusammenhang ordnet und regeln
das ist diese objektive gast ich mache
jetzt kurz die zündung zu ende wird
diskutiert aber vielleicht weitermachen
das ist nett aber das war ich dir bei
diesen dingen ich muss ihn einfach das
nächste mal einfach einen stöpsel ich
habe jetzt hier ein stresstest gemacht